la parole est maintenant monsieur
françois patriat du groupe la république
en marche du sénat pour attendre parole
maximale de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre et dames messieurs
les ministres mesdames messieurs mes
chers collègues le chef de l'état a
tracé le chemin
il nous est donné de vivre un événement
exceptionnel pour créer un véritable
élan la france a besoin d'un choc de
confiance et d'un souffle d'une
profondeur historique et d'une dimension
concrète président de la république
n'est pas venu ici nous entretenir d'un
petit changement politique ou d'un
simple changement de majorité
parlementaire il nous a invités à
contribuer ayons pas peur des mots un
changement de monde
en 1960 john kennedy proposer à ses
concitoyens de réactiver le plus vieux
le plus grand le plus beau mythe
américain en inventant la nouvelle
frontière fait de lutte pour les droits
civiques d'affirmation d'un leadership
actifs sur le monde libre et de conquête
de l'espace devant le grand désarroi
social de notre pays nous avons notre
tour un grand mythe a proposé aux
français pour donner un sens c'est à
dire une direction et une signification
notre action et leur mobilisation
nous devons en quelque sorte continue à
réinventer la république car la
démocratie n'est pas qu'à l'état dont on
peut satisfaire tant dîner cannes et
adzopé satisfaire mais au contraire la
république elle est un projet toujours
inachevée nous allons engager ensemble
cet immense chantier politique autour de
trois mots clés avancer pendant sa
campagne par le chef de l'état le
rassemblement la confiance la
bienveillance les français doivent
d'abord se rassembler et nous allons le
faire
comme un symbole et un exemple d'abord
entre nous on nous perçoit donc un
adversaire déjà mains ennemies pour moi
ici je ne considère aucun des membres de
cette assemblée comme des ennemis et
pourtant des ennemis
nous en avons et sur abonnement avec les
fanatiques qui ont trahi leurs dieux ses
serviteurs de la peur prêcheurs de haine
est porteur de mort
ils croient nous décourager car ils
comprennent qu'ils ne comprennent pas la
force des valeurs universelles et
spécialement de notre choix de l'unité
fondamentale de la condition humaine
nous sommes plusieurs plus fort que par
un paradoxe qu'il ne faut assumer
nous savons que dans le pire des
terroristes il ya aussi un homme si nous
sommes capables de protéger nos
concitoyens contre les menaces
extérieures et intérieures sur leur
sécurité
nous avons fait beaucoup pour les
rassembler c'est pourquoi la
réaffirmation de la place en europe et
dans le monde
une france à nouveau respectée n'est pas
un jeu de rôle du trias trale mais bien
une priorité
les politiques nationales le deuxième
mot clé c'est la confiance il faut le
faire il faut en finir avec la démagogie
6 litres de ce qui nous clame le refrain
du déclinisme et des slogans honteux de
leur complexe d'infériorité collective
en finir avec ces prophètes de
l'apocalypse au petit pied tout au
contraire la france doit afficher sa
confiance en elle même dans le talent de
ses inventeurs dans le génie de ses
créateurs dans l'incroyable vitalité de
ces entrepreneurs
nous n'avons qu'une chose à faire mais
elle est difficile il s'agit de libérer
les initiatives de donner toutes leurs
chances juridiques financières à ceux
qui veulent créer donc favoriser
l'emploi un seul exemple suffira
je le prends dans ce secteur essentiel
de l'environnement le chef de l'état l'a
fait tout à l'heure on peut est ce le
système ancien de droite et de gauche
entretenir la nostalgie coûteuse d'un
monde révolu car il est bien révélateur
que les énergies de la pollution soit
qualifié de faux cils mais nous pouvons
al'inverse dirait démontré qu'une
conversion radicale aux énergies du
futur sera génératrice de milliers
d'emplois c'est à dire pour notre
jeunesse d'une confiance dans l'avenir
retrouvez se rajoute au mot confiance ou
si la dimension d'émancipation
émancipation pour les français pour la
france mais aussi paul et pour les
autres maires qui attendent cette
émancipation avec beaucoup d'impatience
décidément
ne voulons pas de ce monde écrit par le
grand inquisiteur dans les frères
karamazov où le pouvoir échanges aux
citoyens leur liberté dont ils ont peur
contre et la prise en charge de toutes
leurs responsabilités
nous avons au contraire la plus grande
confiance dans la liberté mais nous
savons aussi et le sens et le sens du
mot clé bienveillance que dans un monde
globalisé qui est le chant d'une âpre
compétition
certains sont - armée - formé moins
disposés et parfois même handicapé et la
fille la liberté lorsqu'elle est seule
qui oppriment lacordaire l'a dit avant
nous avant moi ceux là ont droit à la
protection qui dit de la solidarité
d'une société digne de ce nom la réforme
du code du travail ne sera qu'un premier
pas toutes les formes de libération des
forces créatrices doivent accompagner
les garanties qui assureront notre
cohésion et ses deals équilibres
difficiles entre le libéralisme
économique et la protection sociale qui
définit exactement le progressisme dont
nous sommes de nous réclamons voilà ce
que j'appelle réinventer la république
je suis très fier comme beaucoup d'entre
vous j'en suis sûre d'avoir été associé
par le chef d'état à la définition de ce
nouvel horizon militants je veux en
particulier les rendre hommage pour
avoir imaginé le premier que cet immense
effort est possible on attribue souvent
à lénine où elle n'est quoi d'autre
cette formule diminuent ce que vous avez
tous repris là où il ya une volonté il
ya un chemin tout le monde l'a repris et
bien va pour les nous pour un autre mais
je salue cette puissante résurgence il
volontarisme politique qu incarne
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement
j'entends bien sûr parlé ici et là mr
collègues de dérive monarchique de
pouvoir jupitérien ou d'excès d'autorité
à propos de l'adresse du président au
congrès mais je vous dis que tenir de
tels propos c'est préférer les petites
histoires à l'histoire à cette histoire
qui nous vaut convoque et qui nous
jugera dans le pays des lumières et à la
veille de l'anniversaire de la
déclaration d'indépendance américaine
nous sommes réunis pour inventer
l'avenir alors foin des cartes
d'identité du passé foin des étiquettes
dépasserait la république en marche
elle n'est ni de droite ni de gauche on
l'a beaucoup reproché elle
ni à droite ni à gauche qu'on me l'a dit
elle n'est pas au milieu
elle est en avant je vous remercie merci
monsieur patriat
[Applaudissements]